when our next guest um got diagnosed
with covid19
um he said the doctors and nurses not
only saved his life but ultimately
became his guardian angels
uh please take a look at his story
hi my name is kevin devine i'm from
staten island new york i came down with
kovitt on march 20th 2020. they were
pumping me with all different drugs at
the time they thought were going to work
and i was getting worse my oxygen level
was down to almost six it was clear and
simple i was dying the doctor came in
and says kevin i gotta put you on a
ventilator i said to him doc i'm not
going on a ventilator everybody's gone
on a ventilator has died or is dying so
at the time i didn't know her name by
her name is janine young nurse i had two
nights in a row she sits down next to me
at the edge of the bed and goes you
remind me of my dad
and if my father was sitting in that bed
right now i would tell my father to go
on
the ventilator
the next thing i know
i woke up
42 days later the nurse in the room
jumped to the sky
she goes oh my god you're alive
because i was just laying there like in
a coma how to learn how to walk how to
learn how to talk how to learn how to
feed myself i lost 105 pounds
there's no family my son my daughter my
wife couldn't come
so my nurses
they were my angels they you know gave
me that um
hey
you're gonna do it
you're gonna do it you gotta do it
and
one nurse i i never got a hug name i'm
so sorry i didn't came in the room one
night i was having a bad night i i
thanked this nurse to this day
she called my wife and said hey can you
send a picture
so they downloaded it and they printed
it up and the girl brought it in the
room she was hey maybe this will help
and i stayed at that picture
day and night that was my will to get
home my will to get strong my will to
keep fighting
i really wish if she's out there she
sees this
that i can one day get together with her
to tell her how that little gesture for
her meant so much to me
[Applause]
hi kevin how are you i'm just i'm so
moved by your story thank you thank you
for having me i'm so compelled by
so many aspects of your story um
how does it feel for you retelling it
now that there has been some time but
putting yourself back in these moments
it's tough true like watching the video
you can see in my eyes started to well
up mine too yeah absolutely that's
unfair because i pride myself on being
this big tough guy and here i am the
first time i get on tv i got tears in my
eyes so it kind of came off like oh my
god i got to get my composure here and
like i said in the story the young nurse
janine sat at the edge of the bed with
me and told me go on the ventilator you
gotta remember drew i'm watching tv and
everybody on the they're dying
and i don't want to be
i don't want to say this and sound rude
or anything but there was a truck
outside filled with bodies of people who
didn't make it that's how faced people
were dying so now this young nurse
janine i love her i can say she's you're
i'm going to say this line and i hope
you understand what i'm saying she those
three girls are my charlie's angels they
really were
they they they loved them
you know and then and then when i made
the decision i'm in the room and the
nurses on the right nurses on the left
they're putting all these things on me
getting me ready and this one nurse tina
marie i grabbed her hand i said listen
don't let me die
don't let me die and i looked at her and
i said if i die you please let them know
i love them
you let my wife my kids know i love them
i mean i've never seen
so
you're going through that and and while
you're going through all that you you
know next you know the doctor's wheeling
me in that and he's telling the guy the
nsc geologists start hitting you know
immunity with the nfc so guys the unc
charlotte's listening goes why he goes
i'm crying the doctor even said i'm
crying this guy's
the emotion coming through him
and like i said then i woke up
like i said 42 days later
i opened my eyes and the nurse in the
room had her tray and she throws the
tray in the air because she's scared out
of her mouth she looks down at him and
she goes oh my god he's alive
and you know when somebody says it to
you and you're looking around like yeah
i'm alive of course i'm alive am i
supposed to be dead am i should i you
know like you know where was i where am
i and you could remember i got a tube in
my
mouth throat oh yeah i'm trying to
try to say i'm alive i'm alive
and and and then that nurse in that
hospital and i never got in touch with
her yet i hope that somehow somehow
she's watching if you are you remember
the story you have to because i'll never
forget it she came in the room and and i
was having a real bad day and i was
getting upset and she said
let me see what i can do for you and
that drew she just took this upon
herself she reached out to my wife lori
got in touch with lori
and the next thing you know she come in
the room and she showed me that picture
that you saw on the screen
and you know of course you cry because
family yeah
that's all you got
and uh i said that was that was total
motivation
total motivation and true i can't thank
her enough i can't thank her enough
because
i i don't know if i would have made it
you know it's easy
to quit in life thank god for her have
you gotten to speak no i have not gotten
to speak to her that's why i hope in one
way or another somebody gets this to her
and i would love love to to to get
together without one time
well i have someone else here that i
want to surprise you with oh no no
you're not i am um
it's actually uh the doctor that you
spoke of um dr victoria tweeto if you
don't mind coming out please thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
so much lori his wife is here and i
can't thank you enough for being here
because hearing either can i story nick
and i thank you
thank you
thank you
victoria you are a doctor i am a doctor
and in that moment what was it like for
your perspective
uh well i was a brand new doctor i was
actually still a fourth year medical
student and then there was an emergency
call to graduate all those fourth year
medical students to increase the number
of doctors that could work and i had
done all my training at that hospital
and i just figured in a time of man this
was a good way for me to give back and
take a little bit of control
and i actually met kevin after his
critical illness had already passed and
i think that when you think of you know
the ics and the intensity obviously that
part is very difficult to get through
but we also forget that once you've been
in a bed for over 40 days you get
debilitated and there's a lot of work to
do to get back to your normal baseline
and i just saw that he needed family
you know family is what you need to get
through these difficult things how do
you know to do things like that is there
a person a place a thing something in
your life that
catapults you to have that intuitive
nature i just that's what i was brought
up doing was loving people and taking
care of people and treat everyone as if
they're your own family and that's what
i tried to do for you oh thank god
people like you
thank you dr victoria
and thank you kevin for sharing your
story and your family for being here and
dr victoria
i love your story thank you for sharing
it with us thank you so
so much
[Music]